the movie is set in 1989 and it starts
with a U.S commercial jet in the air the
pilots are chatting as usual when all of
a sudden the plane is struck by another
jet the DC-10 from above this causes the
main pilot to lose control of the plane
hence resulting in its Free Fall with
time running out the first officer goes
to check the engines but to his horror
he finds that every single passenger is
dead and that their corpses are burned
he rushes to the cockpit to relay the
information and in the meantime we see a
strange device on the plane's floor the
very next second of the entire jet
explodes and crashes the scene then cuts
to National Transportation safety board
investigator Bill Smith and his
colleagues who are finding Clues
regarding the plane crash there the
investigators meet a theoretical
physicist named Dr Arnold Mayer Who is
also curious about the crash he believes
that something Supernatural might have
caused it really had this guy get to be
a doctor meanwhile Bill gets handed the
cockpit voice recorder with which he can
recover the Pilot's conversations from
while they were in the air afterward he
along with other investigators goes to
meet the air traffic control officer
Jans after a bit of questioning Jans
reveals that he and three others were
handling 40 flights and were very tired
at the time of the accident however the
strange thing is that when he looked
away from the control screen for a
second he saw the DC-10 plane appear out
of nowhere chance claims that he did
inform the pilots to turn away but by
that time disaster was imminent as he
says this he starts crying so Bill and
the others leave him be friggin well
baby shortly after Bill heads to the
airport Hangar where all the remains of
the plane have been kept there he
notices the ticket agents handing out
coffee including an attractive woman
named Louise Baltimore he calls her and
asks for a cup of coffee but she
mysteriously runs off after seeing him
Bill ignores the strange occurrence and
sits down to listen to the cockpit
recordings a while later Luis finally
brings him and the others their coffee
the two seem attracted to each other and
after she leaves bill notices something
odd while listening to the audio he
hears the first officer yell that the
passengers had already died and were
burned before the plane crashed however
the investigation shows no evidence of a
fire before the crash this confuses all
of the investigators and they conclude
that the first officer might have said
that out of fear and shock after this
bill enters the gymnasium where the dead
bodies and their personal belongings are
being examined the lead examiner shows
Bill a digital watch that somehow is
moving backward in time in addition The
Examiner brings out two other watches
also moving backward further adding to
the confusion because all three of them
couldn't be broken at the same time
later bill is seen answering questions
from reporters in a press conference Dr
Arnold also shows up and pressures him
by asking if the team has found any
unusual phenomena from the crash site
however bill doesn't answer the question
and says that it is confidential
information after the press conference
he decides to go to his hotel and on the
way he bumps into Louise Bill invites
her for a cup of coffee but she proposes
they go out for dinner her instead I
guess they skipped a few more steps
because the scene then cuts to the two
in bed after Belle falls asleep Louise
sneaks into the bathroom then she calls
the room service to cancel Bill's 6 30
a.m wake up the next day the next
morning Bill is frustrated as the hotel
didn't wake him up Louise says that this
might be fate and for some reason tries
to convince him to not go to work
however bill says the investigation is
very urgent he then leaves the room only
to return back in a few minutes after
remembering he left something behind but
to his surprise he cannot find Louise
anywhere and assumes she is run off in
the afternoon during a meeting Bill
calls up the ticket agency and asks for
Louise however the company is not able
to find that name in its records this
makes him believe that she was lying
about her identity at night bill is in
the hangar even after closing time
looking at all the plane remains
suddenly he hears a beeping sound and
then sees a flashing red light beneath
some of the rubble upon further
investigation it's revealed that the
sound is coming from the strange device
which was shown in the beginning when
the plane first crashed Bill fiddles
around with this strange device when all
of a sudden he gets Zapped and falls to
the floor unable to move then three
women wearing some sort of military
outfits run up to him among them one
woman is Louise who now has a completely
different appearance than before in
addition she acts and talks as if it is
the first time she is seeing bill it is
then revealed by one of the women that
the device is called a stunner we also
find out they have come to retrieve it
Louise warns Bill to abandon the
investigation or else a devastating time
Paradox will ensue the women then leave
and walk into a bright blue light and
disappear shortly after Bill stands up
and in his hand is a part of the stunner
which Louise failed to get the scene
then cuts into a futuristic setting and
it is revealed that Louise and the
others are actually time travelers from
a thousand years in the future here
pollution has turned humans infertile
and humankind is on the verge of
Extinction hence a team of the world's
best scientists has sent women into the
past to abduct people who are able to
reproduce the plane crashes were part of
this plan and the abductees are kept in
stasis until they can be sent into the
far future to repopulate the Earth
that's complicated the time traveling
hotties probably could have just said
hey you down and fixed everything as the
team of time traveling women returns we
are introduced to Louise's personal
robot Sherman he tells her that their
Master is calling them so they go into
the control room to meet him their
Master then tells Louise that because
she talked to Bill it has caused the
past to change and this causes a Time
Quake similar to an earthquake Furious
Louise questions her master if she
should have killed Bill however she is
soon told by another one of her
teammates that it would have resulted in
a major time Paradox killing everyone
and giving Tarantino really good ideas
this calms Louise down and shortly after
they watch bill on a screen as he wakes
up when he starts yelling her name
Louise is stunned as she believes she
had just met bill for the first time she
asks Sherman how he could have known her
name the latter explains that in Bill's
timeline however in Louise's timeline
she met him for the first time in the
hangar where she went to retrieve the
stunner afterwards Sherman puts Louise
through a set of tests and scans her
body for another mission to 1963. he
then states that Louise didn't have
enough cigarettes back in 1969. this
indicates that the air in the future has
become so polluted that whenever they
travel back in the past they smoke
cigarettes to mimic their own timeline's
atmosphere Sherman then preps her for
time travel and makes her dress up as an
air hostess following this we are shown
a lecture by Dr Arnold Mayer where he
discusses the possibility of visits from
Time Travelers he goes on to explain
that time travelers prefer not to be
seen by people or they only come into
contact with people who are likely to
never be seen by others again like on a
plane when its crash is inevitable he
ends his lecture by claiming that time
travelers are real we just have less
information about them this better be a
community college elsewhere Louise and
the others leap into the time machine
and travel back to 1963 where they
appear on a plane they use the stunners
to slowly take out the other air hostess
and the passengers as they do so a man
attempts to hijack the plane which
results in a time traveler getting shot
this causes her to drop her stunner
which is found by a boy Louise then uses
her stunner to kill the man after a
while the boy tries to inform her about
the previous stunner he found but Louise
puts him to sleep before he can say
anything afterward the entire back half
of the plane goes through the time
machine into the future it turns out
that the plane in 1963 was going to
crash so teams from the future are sent
into the past to abduct people who will
die from the impact this way no lives
are taken since the people who were
about to die in the plane crash are the
ones being taken to the Future the team
then escorts the passengers out of the
plane and replaces them with identical
clones who are already dead this
explains the first officer's comment on
the bodies being burned before the crash
as the time travelers had pre-burned the
identical clones in preparation for the
crash if you predicted that plot twist
we here at mystery recap owe you a
cookie after that the master discloses
that the man who is about to hijack the
plane was going to shoot toward the
cockpit resulting in a crash hence he
orders the ladies to plant a bomb in the
cockpit so as not to alter the past
which will also prevent any paradoxes
after placing the bomb inside the
cockpit the team then gets off the plane
afterward the wounded time traveler says
that she lost her stunner in the plane
so Louise decides to rush back to the
plane and find it however the bomb in
the cockpit has already started counting
down forcing her to get off in the next
scene we see Louise in a council meeting
with people inside large tubes which
helps them survive due to the harsh
conditions of the future the council
says that the first stunner which she
lost in 1969 ended up in the possession
of Bill Smith and the second one which
she lost in 1963 will eventually end up
in the hands of Dr Arnold Mayer if he
finds out what it can do he might be
capable of figuring out how it works and
might unveil The Truth About Time
Travelers so they decide to risk another
mission back to 19 69 where she will
meet Bill a day before he got the
stunner and prevent him from finding it
in the hangar the scene then cuts into
the past where Bill sees Louise for the
first time while he asks her for a cup
of coffee the movie plays out as it did
before and this explains why she was
trying to convince Bill to not go to
work previously before they go to the
hotel Louise does a bunch of normal
activities very weirdly like driving a
car and eating a salad as in her
timeline these things are not possible
the next day after Bill leaves the room
for work Louise calls to be returned
back to the future and as a result Bill
cannot find her in the room when she
returns shortly after she returns they
experience another time Quake but this
one is much more intense afterward
Louise and the master observe Bill and
realize that instead of investigating
the crash he is searching for Louise and
the answers behind his unusual
experience in the hangar Louise then
says that bill will most probably meet
with Dr Arnold Mayer and discuss her and
the stunner Bill eventually visits
Arnold and it is revealed that the
stunner lost in 1963 wound up in
Arnold's possession which set his path
to investigate what caused the crash
Arnold then shows the stunner to him
while Bill also shows the part of the
stunner that he found in the hangar
unbeknownst to both of them bill is
actually in the possession of the
stunner initiator it is then revealed
that bill was also one of the passengers
who boarded the 1963 plane and was the
only one to survive in fact he is the
same boy that saw the stunner and was
put to sleep by Louise before he could
utter a word meanwhile worried that they
might cause a huge Paradox Louise
decides to pay bill and Dr Arnold a
visit shortly after she materializes
from the future and reveals her mission
to them hoping that the two will
voluntarily keep the secret during the
conversation Arnold accidentally kills
himself while reassembling the stunner
with the help of bill's initiator now
because Arnold was necessary for the
development of the gate technology which
makes time travel possible his death
results in a Time Paradox that will
destroy the entire future civilization
terrified Louise rushes to the time gate
in order to get to the Future however
Bill who has now finally found the love
of his life decides to follow her
through the gate with the intention of
never leaving her side the two jump
through the portal and find that in the
future everything is coming to an end
due to an infinite and intense time
Quake that lasts forever now the only
course of action to save the human race
is to send all the people who were
collected from the planes into the
distant future to repopulate before the
time machine is permanently destroyed so
the master slowly initiates the time
machine after he wakes the people who
were kept unconscious in holding pens he
then orders them to move to the time
portal immediately after everyone is
through the portal Bill prepares to go
through it but stops when Louise says
she has to stay back however Sherman
convinces her to go and start a new life
with Bill it is then revealed that
Louise is pregnant with Bill's child and
so the couple steps through the gate
together and disappears while the
explosions engulf Sherman the master and
all the members of the council let's
hope if they go forward through time
that baby doesn't just explode out of
her tummy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching